finding the right solution for labs
cover 19 testing needs can be a
difficult decision
the challenges are unprecedented and the
options
can be overwhelming perkinhelmer was one
of the first
organizations to develop and deploy
diagnostic tools
in response to the disease outbreak i
would like to take this opportunity to
share our experience
in assisting labs on the front line of
fighting the virus
depending on the desired outcome for the
lab
one or more complementary detection
methods can be employed
real-time pcr assays are used to
identify source code to rna shed by
individuals with an active infection
the results are typically used to
determine treatment and quarantine
plants on the other hand
immunoassays detect antibodies to solve
scope 2 that have been reported to
appear
days after infection and persist for a
relatively longer period of time
immunoassays are a valuable set of tools
for identification of individuals
who have developed an adaptive immune
response
detection and disease surveillance as
well
the vital dynamics of starscope 2 is not
yet fully understood
there is evidence that viral load tends
to correlate with the severity of
infection
reports also suggest the possibility of
cell scope to transmission from persons
who are asymptomatic or asymptomatic
a highly sensitive diagnostic assay with
the ability to detect
low viral load is thus required to
accurately detect the virus and assist
in preventing the spread of infection
automation and assay controls are also
effective tools to ensure reverse
results
labs have reported that supply chain
interruptions have had a significant
negative impact
resulting in delayed results and decline
in requests
received over time vendors with a steady
supply chain and a transparent view
into their supply chain should be
prioritized
materials can be directly sourced from
manufacturers who meet these criteria
many labs also plan to increase capacity
by adding platforms
shifts or expanding their workforce
modular
automation can help labs adapt variable
sample throughput
and reduce exposure of staff to the risk
of lab acquired infections
testing is a complex multi-step process
suppliers
offering a comprehensive ready-made
solution to implement
automated source code through testing
can simplify life for lab
and the lab manager consolidation
to an appropriate vendor can improve
procurement efficiency
and visibility to availability status of
specialized reagents
and equipment lastly
the quality of support can be the
difference between success and failure
for lab
a responsive support team can help
guarantee a better experience by
assisting
in every step along the way from
insulation to analysis
labs should work with suppliers they
trust
the most common methods for vital
identification
are based on nucleic acid or immunoassay
detection
nucleic acid based using real-time pcr
is
widely used as the method for diagnosis
at a high level
there are three steps in the nucleic
acid testing process
which are sample collection sample
isolation and nucleic acid detection
itself
the preferred methods for sample
collection at this point is
oropharyngeal swab mixed differential
swab or anterior
nasal swab the chemical 360 platform
is perkinaro's magnetic beat-based
isolation method
that is ideally suited for automated
sample processing which our customers
have communicated
as being extremely important in such
emergencies
sample isolation plate setup sample
reformatting
and pcr setup can be facilitated by
modular
curriculum and janus workstations
the automated processing culminates in
the detection of the virus
using perkin numerous real-time pcr kits
just as an example labs that are
processing
up to 6000 samples per day with the
setup comprising
four k magic 360 units three janus
liquid handlers
and our tpcr units this sample capacity
can be scaled up or down
as this is a completely modular setup
the heart of this workflow is the
real-time pcr assay
the proclamatory new coronavirus nucleic
acid detection kit
uses tachman-based real-time pcr
technique
to conduct in vitro reverse
transcription of stars curve to rna
dna amplification and subsequent
fluorescence detection
the assay targets specific genomic
regions of cell scope 2
namely nuclear capsid mg and or1ab
and leverages multiplexing capacity to
enable processing
of 94 samples in one run alongside a
positive control and a negative control
the assay includes an rna internal
control
that leverages bacteriophage ms2
to monitor the process from nucleic acid
extraction to fluorescence detection the
internal control probe is labeled with
vic fluorescence dye
to differentiate its fluorescent signal
from starscope to targets
the pacman probes for the two amplicons
are labeled with sam
and rox fluorescent bikes respectively
to generate a target specific signal
the assay has been optimized to produce
results with high analytical sensibility
and specificity
the results confirm a limited detection
of 7.142 copies per ml
for the orf 1ab target and 23.380 copies
per ml
for the end target in oropharyngeal spot
matrix
using the key magic 360 platform the
results also confirm a limit of
detection of eight point three two three
copies per ml
for the out of one a b target and twenty
seven point two four six
copies per mil for the end target in
mesa pharyngeal swap matrix using the
key magic 360 platform
the bilox dna rna 300 kit h96
is designed for automated isolation from
200 microliters of autopharyngeal swab
nasopharyngeal swab anterior maintenance
for
draco alveolar leverage student plasma
or serum
using the k-magic 360 instrument
equipped with a chemergic 96 rod head
set
the isolation process takes just 60
minutes for 96 samples
following which the eluded cellscope to
rna is ready for subsequent analysis
using rtpcr
the full solution for viral isolation
comprises the
the k-magic 360 instrument the chemic 96
rod headset and the kimonogic
vital dna rna 300 kit h96
the 96 volt plate format is well suited
for high throughput nucleic acid
isolation
offers reliable protocols for multiple
applications as well as convenient
sample loading
and online buffer dispensing
the chemojig 360 uses transiently
magnetized rods
to attract the beads after binding to
the nucleic acids
this feature and the concerted rotation
of the rods
allow optimal sample mixing during the
homogenization and washing steps
thereby increasing the yield and purity
of the extracted nucleic acid molecules
the transfer of the magnetic beads
between the tubes minimizes the
possibility
of sample contamination between
purification steps
the liquid handling steps are met by two
configurations of the janus instruments
the first configuration is an automated
alternative for a laborious primary
sample reformatting process
the instrument increases sample
processing efficiency
by reformatting 192 samples in 48
minutes
it also reduces exposure from hazardous
sample handling
and improved sample integrity by
reducing manual errors
the second configuration of the janus
instrument aids in increasing efficiency
by preparing two pcr plates in 16
minutes
the instrument reduces hands-on time and
like its sample reformatting counterpart
improves sample integrity by reducing
manual errors
[ __ ] armor has set up manufacturing
lines across the globe
to meet the growing demand for nucleic
acid testing and mitigate logistical
challenges
in getting kids to our end users the
source code to real-time
rkpc rfc manufactured in finland
it's a c-marked real-time pcr technique
to conduct
in-return transcription of source code
to rna dna amplification
and fluorescence detection each kit has
four components with materials to
process
96 samples in approximately 60 minutes
using 14 microliters of extracted
nucleic acid as input
the assay includes probes for human rna
target that's used as an
rna internal control to monitor the
process from nucleic acid extraction to
fluorescence detection
this test is marketed as an in-vitro
diagnostic device
by meeting the requirements of the
european industrial diagnostic directive
the kit manufactured in a factory in
china
is listed on the who procurement list
the emergency use listing can be
leveraged by other international
regional and national procurement
agencies
until april 2021. a factory in germany
manufactures and supplies a completely
independent line of rtpcr kits
adding to the supply chain the ceilings
so far in this session we reviewed
nucleic acid-based detection methods
copenhagen infection can also be
detected indirectly by measuring the
host immune response to cell scope to
infection
serological diagnosis is an important
method for patients with mild to
moderate illness
who may present late beyond the two
weeks of illness onset
theological diagnosis is also becoming
an important to to understand the extent
of copenhagen
in the in the community and to identify
individuals who are immune and
potentially protected
from being infected
as seen in this plot igm and igg
zero conversion occurs in most
individuals between the third and fourth
week of clinical illness onset
thereafter igm begins to decline and
reaches
lower levels by week five and almost
disappears by week 7
whereas igg persists beyond 7 weeks
several studies suggest that igg
antibody testoscope 2
may represent the primary femoral immune
response protecting patients
against south scope 2. iga
which is not captured in the figured
here has been shown to have a positive
correlation with carbon 19 severity
the first zero conversion day of iga has
been reported to be two days
after onset of clinical symptoms thereby
making this
a strong early diagnosis marker
there is a wide array of technologies
available for antibody detection
the underlying methods fall into four
broad categories
from pokemon as you can see here
depending on the desired outcome and the
labs preference
one or more complementary detection
methods can be employed
superflex is a c marked automated my
luminescence analyzer
capable of detecting igg antibody in up
to 12 samples simultaneously
in 15 minutes using serum plasma or
whole blood as input
kobe screen is a c-marked lateral flow
based assay capable of detecting total
antibody
including iug igm and iga in 20 minutes
using serum plasma or fingerprint whole
blood pass input
gsp delphia is a c-marked time-result
fluorescence-based assay for detecting
ign
igg antibody in up to 5000 samples
every day using dried blood spot or
serum as sample type
euro immune assay is a c-marked
laser-based method for detecting
iug igm or iga antibody
to narrow down the choices based on
lab's needs it might be helpful to read
this table from left to right
row wise if a lab is looking for a fast
assay
superflex or kobe stream might be the
assay of choice that
offer 15 and 20 minute sample processing
time respectively
labs that are looking to process high
sample volume in any given day
might choose the gsp delphia platform
that enables processing up to 5000
samples in a 24-hour day
all the platforms on listed here can
detect igg
but if a lab is looking for iga in
specific
then kovi screen and your immune
platforms are ideal choices
and as a lab is looking for the
nucleocapsid protein
then euro immune offers that choice as
well
in terms of sample types gsp delphia and
neuromu
offer the unique sensation of allowing
dried blood spot as a sample type for
antibody detection lastly
all the platforms here are ce marked
uh with your immune platform being fda
ua approved as well for
igg detection
from here on we'll take a few minutes to
look at each of these platforms
in a little bit more detail starting
with the superflex
platform the superflex anti-sarco igg
kit is an immunoassay intended for
qualitative detection of anti-subscribe
to
igg in human serum plasma and venous
whole blood
on automated chemiluminescence analyzer
this test is intended for use as an aid
in identifying individuals
with an adaptive immune response to
source co2 indicating recent or dried
infection
a specimen is added to a specimen well
and then bound with
magnetic particles coated with source
cover to antigen
after washing acrylium ester labeled
anti-human igg antibody
is added to form an amino complex the
whole device is composed of sample
loading module
reading module magnetic beat processing
module
and reagent strip loading channel
control system and software component
so it's an all-encompassing system
reagents required for sample processing
are supplied in the form of a pre-loaded
cartridge
offering hands-free processing after
initial sample loading step
the user can choose to load up to 24
samples in one batch
or in smaller batches without having to
wait for sample processing of the
previous batch to complete
fast sample processing with minimal
handling and random access
makes the system an ideal screening tool
for labs
moving on to kovi screen as we briefly
touched on earlier
iga has been reported to be an important
diagnostic marker
in a significant proportion of patients
the iga antibodies
appear almost simultaneously and more
importantly iga
isotope appears first with very high
tiders
there are studies showing that the
combination of iga and igg
or iga ign and igg provides
improved diagnostic reliability as
comfort compared to conventional igm igg
combinations
in addition it has been observed that
iga levels in serum
correlate positively with carbon 19
severity
these findings make a compelling case to
consider an iga based antibody assay
that also contains igm and igg
as a companion test to complement rtpcr
spirit is a qualitative double anagen
sandwiched immunoassay for the
simultaneous detection of total
antibodies
including iug igm and iga testoscope
providers incident plasma and whole
blood
it is used for screening or to aid in
the diagnosis of cognitive disease and
exposure to the virus
and the total antibodies are specific to
spike protein and subscribe to virus
are detected in this test kobe screen
utilizes the principle of agglutination
of antibodies with prospective antigen
in immunochromatography format along
with the use of nano-indicator colloidal
particles
as a glutamination revealing reagent
recombinant antigens specific to source
code 2 are coated
in the test region or t region as
indicated here
and biotinylated bromine serum albumin
as acid control in the control region or
c region as indicated here
as the test specimen close to the
membrane assembly within the test device
the colored cytoscope to specific
recombinant
antigen indicator colloidal particle
complexes would be source code to
antibodies
if it is present in the specimen this
complex moves further on the membrane to
the test region
where it is immobilized by the
oscilloscope to recombinant antigens
leading to the formation of a colored
band in the test
t region confirming a positive test
result
absence of the colored band in the test
region indicates a negative test result
the unreacted conjugate and unbound
complex if any
along with the september and colloidal
gold conjugate move along the membrane
and are subsequently immobilized by by
the biotinated
bovine serum albumin ported at the
control c
region forming a colored band the user
should always look for
a c region because the absence of the
c situation band invalidates the test
results
we will now spend a couple of minutes
talking about the gsp
and delphia platform three independently
powerful tools
um come together here in this case to
make an even stronger
antibody detection platform for high
throughput labs
in the form of gsp delphia anti-south
scope to igg kit
the three distinguishing characteristics
being dried blood spot as sample type
the gsp instrument itself and time
result fluorescence technology
dried blood spots have been used in
large scale population screening
programs
since the 1960s the blood spot samples
typically reduces cost and logistical
constraints
associated with collection
transportation and processing
of venous blood samples from cytoscope
to antibiotic testing
these sample types make it easy to
sample from
fingerprint using small volumes of blood
that are easily
shippable in an envelope at room
temperature for context every year close
to 15 million newborns
are screened using over 500 gsp units
that are in operation across the globe
coupled with highly sensitive and robust
time-resolved fluorescence
the gsp delphia igg assay offers tried
and true technology
for high throughput fully automated and
traceable sample processing
for qualitative detection of igg against
source cop2
using human blood specimens dried on
filter paper
and in human serum to ultimately aid as
aid in identifying individuals with
adaptive immune response to source co2
indicating recent or prior infection
lastly for users interested in an amino
acid designed against the nuclear capsid
protein
the perkinometer uranium elisa assay
provides this option as well
n-protein represents the most
immunodominant antigen of the
coronavirus family
in the interest of optimal performance
the euro immune elisa assay is designed
based on choosing
only the diagnostically relevant
epiderms as opposed to the full length
and protein euro immune elixir essays
for iga and igg
designed against the s protein is also
available for users
to summarize the critical considerations
for choosing an assay
include evaluation of the lab's needs
assay performance
availability throughput supply
management and support
parking learners south cove to detection
platforms takes all these factors into
consideration
and offers a broad range of options for
users
thank you very much for your attention